[Music]
a while back i was teaching physics in
california
i got to class and i was all like hey
class you want to hear a physics joke
yeah okay totally
does light hold mass i don't know does
it
no
it's not even catholic oh man she should
have went to the beach
really totally lame but wait
doesn't light really have mass it should
it's called momentum so it's gotta have
mass it adds momentum so it must have
mouse whoa hey everyone just calm the
heck down you see the worst part of all
this wasn't that my joke bombed it was
that i actually managed to confuse
people by telling it my students had
read that light has momentum and they
were right light really does have
momentum but then i come to class and
i'm all like hey guess what light has no
mass now my students are thinking to
themselves dude but p equals mv
in other words if momentum equals mass
times velocity how could light which has
no mass ever have momentum well i had to
break it to my students that p equals m
v
isn't really accurate for things that
travel close to the speed of light for
things going that fast you have to use
special relativity i don't want to waste
a lot of time talking about special
relativity in this video so you're just
gonna have to take my word for it that
the rules of special relativity allow
for a loophole this loophole provides a
way for massless objects to have
momentum
all right so the bad news is that we
cannot use p equals m v to find the
momentum of a photon the good news is
that the formula for the momentum of a
photon is simple the momentum of a
photon equals h over lambda h is
planck's constant 6.626
times 10 to the negative 34th joule
seconds
lambda is the wavelength of the light in
meters be careful don't use nanometers
you have to convert to meters the
momentum of a single photon is going to
be extremely small that's why it doesn't
feel like we're getting pushed on very
much when light shines on us but
theoretically if you had a big enough
solar sail the light bouncing off of
that solar sail could propel it forward
due to the impulse imparted by the
momentum of the light
okay so very long story short you should
never ever use p equals m v to find the
momentum of a photon to find the
momentum of a photon you should always
use momentum equals h over lambda
you